Narrator: Step aside, Atkins,
there's a new fat diet in town.
The ketogenic diet or keto for short.
Celebrities like Halle
Berry, Kourtney Kardashian,
and Vanessa Hudgens all swear by it.
And if losing weight is
your goal, keto works.
It's proven to help you shed pounds fast.
But there's more to this
diet than meets the eye.
Keto basically replaces carbs with fat.
A typical keto diet looks like this.
70% fat, 25% protein,
and 5% carbohydrates.
It's a drastic change from the diet
that the USDA recommends
for most Americans,
which is less than 30%
fat, 20 to 35% protein,
and at least 50% carbs.
And it's a significant change
for your body's metabolism too.
Usually, when you eat carbs
like a starchy potato,
enzymes in your mouth,
stomach and small intestines
break them down into a form of
sugar energy called glucose,
which your brain and body use for fuel.
So when you first skip out on carbs,
the first couple days you might experience
some strong sugar cravings.
That's because your
body is switching gears,
from converting carbohydrates
to the only energy it has left: fat.
Once you're burning fat regularly,
you'll see those pounds
start to melt away.
Depending on your weight,
you might lose up to 3.5
pounds within that first week.
As you burn more fat, levels of insulin,
the fat-storing hormone,
will drop significantly.
This triggers your kidneys
to release large amounts
of sodium into the blood
which can actually lead
to a common side effect
known as the keto flu.
Many keto dieters report
symptoms like nausea,
headaches, dizziness, muscle
cramps, and low energy levels.
But most of these symptoms will only occur
within the first couple
weeks of starting the diet.
After the first month, the
scales will look better
but some of that lost
weight isn't actually fat,
it's just water.
Because some of the carbs you metabolized
include glycogen which retains water
and therefore helps keep you hydrated.
As a result, you're
likely to pee more often
which will lower your
sodium levels even more
leading to dehydration,
constipation or diarrhea,
and bad breath.
Once you're a couple months in,
you might hit the notorious keto plateau.
It's a common term in the keto community.
It refers to when people
find it progressively harder
to continue to lose more weight.
One study, for example,
found that overweight people
lost an average of 15
pounds in the first month.
Another 11 pounds over
the next two months,
but after that, they saw
no change in body weight
despite sticking to the keto diet.
At this point, many people
will just quit keto.
That's why researchers
often find it's so hard
to study the long term
effects of the diet.
But, as it turns out, there's one group
that typically sticks to
keto for a really long time.
It's unclear why, but keto is proven
to reduce the symptoms of epilepsy
and studies show that epileptic children
who stay on a very restricted
keto diet for several years
can suffer from kidney stones,
high cholesterol, and bone fractures.
But a typical keto diet
won't be nearly as strict.
And if you wanna try keto,
you should talk to your doctor first.
In the meantime, go
ahead and get that bread,
and remember, the best
diet is a balanced one
of fat, protein, and yes, even carbs.